savvy thank the snowboy baby check me
out on the bullet cat podcast let me be
clear april 29th let's get it
bullet cab podcast we got a special
guest in here one of the hottest
in the city shout out to long beach yeah
savvy third is here yes sir welcome
welcome it's been a long time coming man
yeah man for real first of all we got to
just say shout out to your necklace is
this a new necklace this [ __ ] is uh oh
yeah that [ __ ] is serious yeah it is man
i i finally i finally was patient enough
to to wait on the jeweler to you know
make me something that [ __ ] is
that's just nice yeah this is my
original logo that's the first logo i
ever had what's that what's something
like that run somebody
uh
i mean you know did you get a discount a
pretty penny pretty penny uh yeah i
didn't get i didn't really get a
discount um
but
it was worth it because you know i spent
with him so in the future he gonna uh he
gonna look out did you get the watch at
the same time separate person i got the
watch probably like like two weeks prior
oh damn so you yeah so so that guy was
happy to see you when you came back yeah
yeah they dropped that bag on me i had
to do right that's what's up man
um well look bro it's good to see you
it's crazy because
when me and head were doing the show
together
at real there was a couple of times
where i feel like you were supposed to
come up to the station but then
whatever kind of
uh
miscommunication we'll call it with you
and whack was going on
um
but nonetheless it's good to see you
yeah yeah man you know
i uh
when devo told me like you know like
yeah i'm like man i was being supposed
to yeah you know what i'm saying sit
down and chop with him on air
but uh
i feel like it was me so it's happening
now yeah how is everything good with you
and whack at this point like now
everything solid thing everything is
closure yeah
so are you officially because i saw the
empire logo on the back of the uh the
new album
um
you're officially independent um or
what's what's your situation now the
situation
i'm still in talks with cash money
you know about making everything right
regular cash money cash money west i
mean uh it's cash money in the u.s okay
okay but it's cash money everything
under cash money i'm saying but it's
cash money wags at the end of the day uh
but uh yeah i've been talking with them
i've been talking about whacking uh and
birdman
you know uh we agreed that you know i'm
saying we gotta finish where we started
right right right but um
before that
it was just it was an independent
situation
and uh i did like a little project deal
with empire you know what i'm saying
just for this project see how it go and
uh
everything
you know went smooth but
i like right now as of like like
officially i'm independent but
more than likely
i'm gonna go to cash money right again
you're end up going to cash money again
yeah yeah i feel it's uh it's only right
because weren't you the first artist on
cash money west exactly there it is yeah
yeah and then you ended up getting
incarcerated right
um that is one thing i feel like with
you and in particular
there's a lot of like
what ifs
you know what i mean because you have so
much momentum behind you
and then you end up incarcerated or you
end up in some [ __ ] like
do you feel like um
you kind of had to go through all that
to kind of
really appreciate your position in the
music industry definitely bro uh
like in the beginning ain't gonna lie i
did
exactly
like what you're not supposed to do but
i was a young high head like if i had
the mindset i got now
when i first um got my deal and
everything like [ __ ] would have went
totally different
because you know i got like a way more
level head on me and i'm way more mature
so um i just feel like like you got to
go through life experiences to learn i
learned from it though definitely you
know i'm saying sometimes you'll be real
detrimental to your journey but
it's about how you get back up how you
bounce back how you bounce back bro and
i feel like
at the end of the day i told myself like
i can't let nothing stop me
you know
[ __ ] might not go as planned
but just stay on course did you start to
notice that there was like a negative
stigma about you in the industry yeah
for sure your name was i hated it i hate
it
uh
like the jail [ __ ] it's just not cool
you know what i'm saying but like people
don't know
behind the scenes all they see is
back to jail
like when you're on parole and [ __ ]
especially being in the city and [ __ ]
like they take you to jail for anything
any little thing you could be hanging
out with exactly i was i was at a dmv
one time somebody broke a window i'm
right there the police pull up i'm the
only one no parole they take me to jail
for that's crazy [ __ ] like that so
but that happened yeah exactly yeah we
were just at the dmv i went sure that
happened they
charging for vandalism ended up getting
dropped but it's the fact that the
public sees savvy there going back to
jail right that's all they see they
don't know what four know what's going
on they just think i'm on [ __ ] it's
bad for business so
the best way is to stay out the way and
you know what i'm saying just show
improve are you starting to learn that
now like are you kind of only stepping
out when you need to yeah for sure i
don't i don't party i'm not doing my
party is a studio that's my fun
that's that's my that's my fun place
like only time i'm ever in the club is
if i'm getting paid to be there yeah you
got to get a bag period i'm not doing no
partying
like i'm not popping out have you um
had to kind of um
i guess shed some of your inner circle
because i think sometimes when you go
through adversary you start to kind of
people kind of start to show their true
colors you know what i'm saying did you
notice your your circles getting smaller
uh
my circle it was like from the beginning
my circle the ones that i counted like
as
a part of my circle i knew that
like
that's what it was before it is
and i know that these the [ __ ] that's
gonna be here you know what i'm saying
so anybody outside of that like it could
be immediate people right outside that
circle but i always knew my circle's
still the same the exact same there's
nobody that was there before that's not
there now right like my circle is only
it only consists of like four or five
people right you know what i'm saying
but it's immediate people outside of
that that i might associate with
and
they might act away
i'll tell myself i expected that you
know i'm saying that's why they're not
in my circle
that's fair um are you still on
probation yeah how much longer before
you're like off papers probably like
eight months nine months well that's not
bad that's not bad at all that's coming
up yeah for sure so you know how long
were you actually like on probation
because uh okay so when i when i got out
to penn
get i was on pro for three years and i
can get off early when you know
what year was that that was
2018. okay
and well 2017. and my uh my discharge
parole day was in 2021. i caught a
violation it got extended six months
boom i ended up getting off parole but i
still had an open case that i just got
out for
boom so i went back
did that time little uh 14 months
i just got out in january normal um
probation for
six uh 18 months but they said that they
let me off
in 12 months in a year so you know what
i'm saying when you get locked up are
you like
like
i mean when you're an artist of
notoriety like you are in the city like
is is your experience any different than
anybody else's yeah for sure uh first of
all when you
like in la county there's no there's no
jail like la county jail explain
period like that's
that's gonna make a man aren't you
that's if you if you you know what i'm
saying you um walk in the main line in
the blues like when you first get there
and they know you're a pressure another
notoriety
they're gonna like you know ask you if
you want to be on a celebrity road
that's that's high power
like you always got to escort with you
you want a single man cell you're not
with general population
uh you basically protect custody i'm not
going for that you know what i'm saying
uh i'd go for that just for the record
yeah no i'm saying i'm i'm saying i'm
saying uh uh
yeah yeah for sure sign me up for that
one yeah for sure yeah sure i understand
i understand
but uh
just from my perspective coming from
already right like being there yeah yeah
you know what i'm saying it's just
like it won't stay right with my
conscience but
i say that to say
like like when you walk in the main line
you in that and you in the main part of
that l.a county jail wayside man central
you know what i'm saying it's real
they're gonna test you you're gonna you
gotta you know what i'm saying you gotta
stick it out how different is that than
prison though have you been to prison
yet yeah yeah i've been involved yeah so
what what is that because prison i feel
like you're there a lot longer i feel
like county jail is usually short-term
[ __ ] right okay see uh it depends
because well sometimes it depends on if
you fight what type of case you're
fighting what you're waiting for me i
was uh i was in the county for seven
months got shipped up to the pen i was
only there for four months before i got
released now the difference between uh
the county and the pen safety wise is
much different because
you know uh
you gotta fight like me i'm from long
beach
saying and
my gang
we we got the most rivals in the city so
when we in the county we fighting all
them [ __ ] that's from
when you get to the pen
the whole long beach is one card
so you're so you're it's a little more
chill in the pan way more chill like in
my mind county jail you're you're on
your toes all right yeah the [ __ ] that
i fought in the county when i see these
[ __ ] in the pen they're my homies now
ah
because everybody in long beach is
together right
gotcha that's in the
penitentiary but in the county jail that
don't go county jail's got to be wild
because you got all these homeless
people probably getting locked up every
day there's gotta be [ __ ]
some real gang [ __ ] aside just crazy
weird
[ __ ] who are coming down off of
being high
no they coming down and they're going to
find it again in there they got every
drug whatever you want to be [ __ ] in
the county man cell phones whatever bro
in county jail everything yeah i knew in
prison they had everything yeah la
county is different bro we got you know
i'm telling you that [ __ ] is
rocking so you might have fought
somebody in the county jail and then six
months later
you're with them in in the pen because
you guys walk in the yard with him
spending laughs with him wow that's
actually happened yeah oh that's [ __ ]
crazy
it actually happened to me
i see a [ __ ] in the county boom i'm in
a pan with them
we cool chopping it up
get back to the county cinema county
again i didn't want to fight
what yeah does this
if you could put [ __ ] aside to be in
prison with somebody could you put [ __ ]
aside on the streets with somebody but
it'd be it'd be how you uh it'd be how
how you care what other people view of
you he had a a lot of onlookers you know
what i'm saying
so now at the time that we was in the
pen together i wasn't savvy third like i
am now right now we're back in jail
together i'm savvy third and i'm his
main enemy so now these [ __ ] looking
at me like you're not gonna not gonna
get down with that [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying so he's trying to get up on
me like you know what i'm saying we
gotta stop the interview real quick man
shout out to our sponsors at blue chew
the good thing about blue chew not only
does it make that dick [ __ ]
you know what i mean
get that thing swinging like it never
swang before
but what i love about blue chew is
it's all online man you know usually
when you want to go and get some of that
uh you know some of that good good some
of that blue juice maybe some viagra
first of all it's got the same exact
active ingredients as viagra and as
cialis but you don't have to go into the
doctor's office to get it all right all
you got to do is go to bluetooth.com you
have an online consultation and then
they discreetly
send it to you and it's also discreet
villain you know what i'm saying
it's crazy let me tell you something
maybe you got a first date you want to
make sure you blow them back out that
day you know what i'm saying
pop that blue chew it's a chewable form
some people don't like swallowing pills
ladies are going to love to swallow you
though once you're on that blue chew
i'll tell you that much bud for sure so
what you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com
use the promo code bootleg and you're
going to get a month supply of blue chew
for free all right you're going to thank
me later for this you know when i was a
kid
snoop dogg was like doggy style changed
my life
and all i thought of la was i thought
long beach and l.a were the same thing
you know what i'm saying
yeah definitely not politics are way
different yeah i mean uh
it's not way different it's just we we
we we two different cities you know i'm
sure right like when it comes to the
gang [ __ ] i mean it's pretty much like
the same politics everybody's gonna fall
under it i just mean in terms of like
you know there's [ __ ] that happens in
long beach it doesn't affect what's
going on in hell yeah no not at all same
thing with like the valley the valley's
gotta take [ __ ] you know
whatever happened to long beach i got
nothing to do with l.a which is part of
the county yeah yeah and so when i came
out here and i'm like oh long beach is
kind of a drive oh [ __ ] and then you go
to long beach and if you don't
go to long beach you just go to like you
know we're a complex conference you're
like oh this [ __ ] is nice it's a yard
house there's a good restaurant yeah
that's downtown yeah yeah so yeah i mean
i think long beach has somehow become
one of the more underrated areas of l.a
in the last like 10 years yeah for sure
long beach is uh zombies we got some in
the water it's like yourself uh stupid
young
shout out to stupid young shots i didn't
know they were asian crips until yeah i
moved out here i said [ __ ]
yeah bro
they don't play they do not play they
don't play you know telly they are
serious about it dude does your uh
set like function with those guys [ __ ]
with them you [ __ ] with a man
and then they got their own [ __ ] right
they got it they got their whole little
they got the whole movement going that's
what i'm saying with the samoans and the
in the cambodians out there we got a
whole cambodian town
cambodia town in long beach town to camp
yeah yeah
i think stupid young told us about it
yeah man i really [ __ ] with them yeah um
so with this new project uh who was on
the album
uh
we got ramble
we got uh
shorty shorty shorty shout out baltimore
oh
we got uh mahji shout out to mozart
uh
oh and dom
yo the dom i saw the dom feature that's
a big one well yeah yeah that's my man
how did that happen
um
he don't do features for just anybody
yeah i know i know uh he uh he reached
out well i seen him on uh
i seen him shout me out on um
on one of the radio stations he was
doing the interview i reached out to him
and [ __ ] and um he just told me link up
i went to the studio we just started
making
a bunch of [ __ ] we got like four dope
ass songs oh [ __ ] honestly um i i think
i mentioned this in one interview i did
with sure uh
uh he executive producing a whole
project for me that's big and the track
that's on my album
it was supposed to be on there but i i
asked him like let me have it for the
for the uh for my album he was like go
ahead so a whole other project he's
going to execute a project oh [ __ ] how
much of that one is done
uh probably probably half
not even half not even any hit boy
production
um
i think that one i'm not sure i'm not
gonna say that but i i believe hitboy is
probably one song that we did
i'm not sure though so i ain't gonna say
yeah who's like somebody in la that
you're a fan of in the same way he said
he's a fan of you who are you [ __ ]
with uh that you haven't worked with yet
um let me see
uh
damn let me see man uh
oh caitlin
caitlin kevin's joke caitlyn we ain't
worked that's my brother though right we
worked but we ain't uh we ain't finished
it great guy great guy i love caitlyn i
love him uh [ __ ] love him too yeah
but they love him yeah it's cool sure
asian women love him i was in san diego
dj and i had like eight asian women come
up and they're like i love kayla play
more casually caleb and i love kayla for
real
yeah um [ __ ] yg
why'd yg be hard yg uh sure gotta work
with yg have you worked with snoop yet
yeah that's big right having the [ __ ]
yeah we got some good god of this rap
[ __ ] from your city yeah
that's gotta that had to be a big deal
yeah i traveled over snoop a lot yeah
you gotta have to put you on that
metaverse [ __ ] man yeah man for real i
don't know he got it going on he's
making all the money telling you he
doing mexican songs
anything
that is one thing about snoop you got
the bag right he'll pull up he gonna get
that bag you don't care where he can put
on sombrero and chocolate whatever you
what whatever you come on i was driving
through uh
listening to the radio and he was doing
uh a dick pill a commercial i'm not even
lying
snoop dogg was voicing the detail
commercial i said all right snoop yeah
he called call of duty he's [ __ ] mark
martha stewart yeah snoop snoop is man i
saw a video i saw a video he did with
some like chinese artists uh
the whole video was it like uh whatever
their language is yeah exactly he came
through in the video and the whole time
the crazy part about the whole time he's
doing it he's literally on instagram
active all day long every single day
monday through sunday he's he just
posted right now literally
and still got all this [ __ ] going on he
posts a lot shout out to snoopy how can
you have time to still be this active on
instagram he's an inspiration that's
crazy a pure inspiration for sure man
sure for real um yeah like it's crazy
because you coming into the game being
the first artist uh on cash money west
obviously blueface comes after
kind of blows up the brand but like
was it whack or was it birdman who was
who who who's like uh
radar did you get on first i guess he's
definitely whack everything is wack you
know i'm saying why uh
he's seen me
he's seen me um doing a little freestyle
like on my real come up you know i'm
saying you see me doing a card freestyle
um
he was following one of my one of my
homies and they posted it he seen it
boom and reached out and uh in the
beginning when he was telling me like
man birdman gave me the keys
uh to start cash money west and find
whatever i want i didn't really believe
him you know what i'm saying but well
hey i'm gonna say this about whack man i
i've never witnessed whack
lie i've known whack for a long time
he'll say some [ __ ] that you'd be like
yeah
yeah he exaggerated but he ain't gonna
lie he on our show is where he talked
about the second sex tape with ray j
hill yeah
and everybody's like nah full of [ __ ]
full of [ __ ] look she's talking she was
talking about it on the new [ __ ] uh
kardashian show she was stressed out
because it was it existed black knows
some [ __ ] oh he knows some [ __ ] man i'm
telling don't play with him you know
that [ __ ] got secret he's got a lot he
knows he know nigga's secret he does
yeah whack is that gonna leave it there
i love whack i love wack though for sure
i always i think wax one of the more uh
brilliant
guys in the music industry and i say
that and i truly mean it i know some i
know he's he's you know he's
wack's going whack
whether it's there's always a new
[ __ ] headline
he needs to stay the [ __ ] off clubhouse
i've told him this mike why are you on
clubhouse every day yeah like right now
you're rich you talking right now yeah
uh but like when you see like him like
start to like link up with like a six
nine like does that like does that you
know cause obviously you're cut from a
whole different cloth right i mean uh
and i understand his position it's a
whole different this is that street
business entertainment business i get it
yeah man you know what i'm saying we at
me and wack we come from the same
backgrounds you know what i'm saying
like when you when you're growing up we
got the uh locked up yeah one time yeah
we applied
the same code applied to us
but when it comes to business
why he do what he do you know what i'm
saying we as long as ain't got nothing
to do with me it's good
i ain't gonna
uh
uh base my decisions or my moves off
nothing that he do with somebody else
for nothing or or judge it or whatever
because that's what he doing you know
what i'm saying at the end of the day he
ain't got nothing to do with me what uh
ended up kind of bringing you two back
together uh out because there was
definitely some static yeah um
uh
uh
at the end of the day i
i grew up and realized that
it'll be it'll be more in my best
interest to
to to
you know make things right at the end
because i knew it was me and he took a
chance on you period
at the end of everything it takes a big
man to yeah i know it was me i own some
[ __ ] yeah it was ultimately me
like you know i just i didn't have my
hat on straight
and i'm you know
what's uh why not give it another chance
if it ain't if it ain't too broken you
know i'm saying so you know we made sure
i had to make sure right yo we got to
stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our partners at odd socks
watch this i bet you i got socks on
right [ __ ] now
oh yeah see them bad boys these are what
we call the odd socks basics the ankles
the ankle socks all right go to
oddssocksofficial.com right now
put the website up promo codes bootleg
cab you're going to save 20 off at
checkout they got so many crazy ass
socks we got twizzlers [ __ ] halloween
uh
i mean these are kind of satanic it just
says demon
they were like let's just do a generic
demon sock
i mean this is kind of like a
i guess like if you were in the 80s in
miami doing cocaine off of a stripper's
[ __ ]
jaws pepsi i mean listen breaking bad
nickelodeon we keep going but what's
most important is odd socks is our
family
look if you support odd socks you
support the bootleg cat podcast so go to
bootleg kev well you can go to
bootleghead.com and just check it out
but you could also go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev and save
20 off at checkout do that [ __ ] right
now all right let's get into the
interview that we've already been inside
of but we're gonna get back to it right
now now that you're uh you're working
with uh
a good friend of mine uh dave shout out
to dave oh
one of the more young uh
just brilliant executives in the in the
rap game um
you know he works with mozzie uh
working with him like what's that been
like and how did you guys end up linking
up
um
it was just so uh genuine it happened so
genuinely you know what i'm saying
and uh davos somebody he gonna he gonna
he he got a thousand things going on
a thousand different artists but he's
gonna
make sure that uh
that you're okay if he's dealing with
you like he gonna give you his all and
that's just one thing i always uh
respected him for and commended him for
that uh he was just thorough you know
what i'm saying it was just uh
you know he made sure that i got
what i had coming to me and and showed
me that he really like believed in me
you know what i'm saying like i want to
make something happen and see you sean
so let me try to do this so he you know
he made the [ __ ] happen with empire
and uh
you know he it's a lot of [ __ ] that he
do behind the scenes so much a lot man i
got a lot of respect for dave i love
that [ __ ] man for real it's crazy too
because i kind of see like um
you know i remember when i first met
mazza he was kind of a
he's not the mature measured guy he is
now
i just he was a little off the chain
he was moving around kind of crazy
but you know i feel like he had to kind
of go through whatever he had to go
through and and i feel like you're kind
of in the same
space so you have to grow uh so the new
project's dropping and then right away
are you well what's the dom project um i
mean see i'm not gonna i ain't gonna
because i don't i just know that that's
the that's that's gonna work
i said it works so is this going to be
your final project before you do the
cash money thing uh
or to be continued yes
excuse me this is to be continued right
now i just wanted to get this one out
with empire let me be clear because uh i
know they needed this we've been working
on it for some years now and it's
finally ready put it out and then uh
after that i'm i'm probably gonna drop
another tape
in a couple months just to feed them you
know what i'm saying and then uh you
know
because uh
i'm still i'm still in the works with
with the cash winning thing so i don't
know trying to figure that out yeah i
don't know how fast we're moving you got
to keep you got to heat up keep keep
keep keep [ __ ] hot until but at the same
time uh
i'm keeping everybody in the loop on
what i'm doing you know what i'm saying
so
maybe they want to move right now maybe
they want to move in a couple months but
i just know that i'm going to stay
consistent with this [ __ ] um
mozzie shared his spread recipe with us
what's your when you were locked up what
are you putting in the spread uh
okay first of all i'm i'm a person i
don't eat nothing spicy nothing spicy i
hate spicy no hot sauce no hot sauce
but i might put the hot pickle in there
okay i'm gonna put the hot pickle in
there but i'll start off you know a
couple of noodles well it depends on if
i'm eating the rice bowl because you
know i'm i was i was a fly [ __ ] out
there so i was eating rice balls every
day having the asians make my rice balls
just giving them the food and [ __ ] what
the [ __ ]
yeah cause the rice ball is just rice
and a bunch of exotics
the asians in prison have like their own
yeah the asians make the best rice balls
everybody know that
so you go to the asian salad you give
them you give them
it depends on what they want you could
either um throw in the food for them to
have a bowl too or just pay them like a
dollar or two or three you know they'll
make it and they make your [ __ ] up and
have it ready for it what the [ __ ] oh
yeah
yeah they grill the meat got the grill
in the in a cell yeah got the uh we take
the hot plate out the hot pot
so you kind of just know who sells like
the benihanas of this word get around
where you get around who's who it's like
a [ __ ] restaurant it's really like a
prison is like a mini
it's just a mini uh world so if the
asians have the rice bowls got somebody
that fixing [ __ ] got the white boy up
there his name uh
uh [ __ ] uh mcgowan
he fixed everything anything you like
trying to give your earphones blow out
here and rewind them uh your tv blow out
you get it you know what i'm saying it's
always at least one person that i do
this [ __ ] that [ __ ] is crazy is it what
because like when you're when you're
locked up like they let they'll let you
have the hot plate in there in prison i
mean you're not supposed to have you
don't know you're not
you know so there's a guy fixing [ __ ]
there's the guys making rice bowls
there's somebody doing everything right
drawing somebody that do the drawings
the best tattoo artists uh you ever get
[ __ ] up off of the wine they make in
prison they got like oh yeah
like [ __ ] up like faded yeah yeah yeah
by the lightning
what's the lightning the white it's the
uh they burn the wine they burn it
and it turned into white lightning
that's way stronger it's like it's like
moonshine yeah exactly like like a
secret gin
you know what i'm saying like that bumpy
face she's like 50 for for uh for a 20
ounce bottle 50 bucks 50 bucks
damn that's cheap
how do you get someone fifty dollars
jp now now it's cat now cash at booming
everybody got cash everybody's got cash
up in everybody got cash
what percentage of people have a phone
in there you think you had a guess uh
everybody can't afford the phone in
there ain't gonna live so
probably not a lot of [ __ ] it depends
on like it depends on if the yard
booming because like on the one and two
yard low level yards damn that everybody
got a phone cause they so cheap you know
i'm saying it depends on
how flooded it is and how does a phone
get into the jail i don't know is it a
guard is it someone shoves it up their
ass they get in there jesus they get in
there
inside of orifices of baby mamas get in
there man man
that's crazy i mean yeah it's crazy
because you think in prison you can
pretty much get anything right yeah for
sure are you able to like listen to
music at all stream music hell yeah if
you got a phone
yeah but if uh uh
[ __ ] if not if you got like a little
tablet
will they give you a tablet yeah you can
buy a tablet and then have somebody rig
it and then like visiting how your
people bring up a [ __ ] memory card
chip with all your [ __ ] on oh [ __ ]
is there wi-fi in the jail no damn so
you need the phone service yeah no wi-fi
and eventually the phone service is
sketch as [ __ ] it depends
[ __ ] probably booming oh wow
you got cricket you're [ __ ]
and maybe it depends for boost
i don't know i had uh what did i have i
had 18g
and there was no phone blockers
yeah
one time during the pandemic i was like
going on live with artists you know
just listening to music and i went on
live with some guy he was in the [ __ ]
pen yeah with like all his homies in
their show and he seemed like a
freestyling for me on ig live i'm like
what the [ __ ] is going on yeah it's
going up how the [ __ ] are the guards and
i know what's going on music video man
do the guards really give a [ __ ] uh
it depends on you know most of them are
probably yeah most of them
people be forgetting that they are
people too you know and they're normal
they're not even cops exactly yeah
normal people but you got those it's
just a good job with [ __ ] benefits
you got those guards that that really
take this [ __ ] serious and be robo cops
but like like like
most of the time if most of the time
you'd be more cool cops than not
but the other cops know that that's why
they [ __ ] because they know
it's a lot of cool cops and they don't
want to be a cool cop i don't know why
like just come get your bag and go home
yeah just get your benefits
go home you're doing all this extra [ __ ]
was there ever any riots when you were
locked up i've been i've been in two
rides
how crazy does that get it's real yeah
that [ __ ] real bro i ain't gonna lie is
was it race related was it it was some
race right [ __ ] so what was that was it
blacks vs mexicans oh [ __ ]
that's wild it got cracking man so if
the if that [ __ ] pops off like what did
do most people stay out of the way a lot
of people
they tuck their tail bro like you can
see a lot of [ __ ] stuck they tell you
like [ __ ] help me i'm like you know
what i'm saying afterwards in the hole
when everybody in the hole together
you screaming out nigga's name like whoa
dude he didn't do nothing i've seen that
ain't hiding over there in the corner
he's just looking at me like
you ain't gonna forget that but uh
but but but something you're gonna see
what a [ __ ] made of when that happened
when i in that moment you're gonna
you're gonna see what you made uh so in
like cause cause um
how many so in southern california
obviously there's the south siders the
mexicans
who do you guys click up with in in jail
race wise or is it just blacks
it's just blacks
do the mexicans well we [ __ ] with the
others like um
the others the others like the asians
and the uh okay and the samoans and
those those are called asians so the
others are just kind of like there's not
enough people
sometimes the others just like maybe
someone from india yeah they're the
others these other yeah yeah like you
know um
anything of that ethnicity japanese
chinese so it's the blacks and the
others yeah the others they fall under
the black and is it who what about the
white the white supremacists
they run with the maxims damn yeah
that's f who's the most powerful in
prison
numbers-wise
um it depends on what what yards you
land on
you do like i was i was in a i was in
delano a yard it's a three yard it was
dominantly black
it was a dominant black yard but then
you know the mexicans they always did
that is true they always d they are in
california they always got numbers so
ultimately you'll beat them
but it'd be some some some uh yards
where
like because having in asia it's pretty
much like the aryan nation and then the
mexicans yeah and then
there's not that many black people in
arizona yeah i mean so
the aryan nation and then the mexican
mafia
i don't think they're friends from what
i understand
they don't play a lot of words too
they don't play yeah they run their own
program for sure but they're going
they're going you should about pecker
woods right the woods the whites the
white people the white people
they call woods yeah the pekka was the
woods you know what i'm saying he wrote
wood but uh they they do their own thing
but like in the county it won't be that
many woods they immediately
run with the mexicans you know what i'm
saying immediately but at the end of the
day that's who
like when it's time to pick a side
that's gonna be together and this is
gonna be together what if it's like a
okay let me ask you this right because
there's like certain
people we know
that are white
who
[ __ ]
our [ __ ] or they yeah okay one of those
guys gets arrested that was that was the
first riot i've been in because it's
some [ __ ] like that so do they go with
y'all or do they go with the race they
come they come if they come with us the
race is gonna impress them the white boy
is going to press up this if they
tripping you like like this what
happened
a white blood came to the dorm
and i [ __ ] he was a straight white boy
carrot top
and the woods walked up to him trying to
introduce himself and you know show them
the program he was like what i'm gonna
know
he like i'm i'm a gang member i'm from
he was a blood he would you oop and it
was like what
that the
uh the rep for the woods he wasn't
having that he was tripping so he came
to our rep like i'll get him out of here
or
it's going up
so when you say get him out of here
like like they they like y'all going he
got to go or he's going up
and did it go up it went up oh
over a white guy who wanted it because
he's running without he running with the
black so we're going to stand by him
which is a crate which is like very uh
rare
uh
it's not rare what about what was there
ever been a mexican blood or a mexican
[ __ ]
yeah
does that get does that oh there he's
right there
allegedly allegedly
allegedly
but yeah we have one here in the studio
so if he hits the yard he hit the yard
okay so he hits the yard and i was
waiting
he's with y'all what else
so are they not trevor in the match the
mexicans don't give a [ __ ] they don't be
true white people are on that white
prize we got black well i'd have been on
the yard with black
um black dudes that wrong with the mess
and they for mexican game there's black
guys who are in mexican games oh yeah i
had no idea yeah so that i didn't know
[ __ ] yeah there's black sounds talk
exactly like them look just like me yeah
fool yeah
seriously
are there any rappers like that
and they rap like mexican little robs
or black little robs
what if you're just a normal white guy
and you're not racist and you're not
involved in the underbelly of the [ __ ]
you end up in prison where do you end up
i'm asking you
you have to right i can't just be like
i'm just by myself and myself i want to
go to the library eat alone you're gonna
run with the white boy you have like
there's no they're going they're going
they they're going uh there's no are you
saying there's no choice if you go to
prison you have to be involved in some
policy you're going to period
no matter what yeah
yeah you're going to follow you can't
just be like i'm just trying to just
hang out i don't know get my because my
time out on this time because when it's
riot time
you need to be accounted for when it's
time to go you need to be what if it's
riot time and i just lay on the ground
like this they're going to beat your ass
they're going to blast you out your
boots
so it's better to just go ahead throw a
couple punches get it over because the
consequences afterwards it's going to be
way worse do the gay fools link up is
hell no is that like their own click
we're not on the yard with the gay fools
oh they're they're they're they're
they're a piece okay okay okay so the
gays are with the uh child molesters
yeah
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you
that's our kookabee [ __ ] from
san francisco
yo we gotta stop the interview real
quick tell us about uh i'm gonna tell
you about our partners in my bookie man
make sure you go to mybookie.ag right
now
it's gambling season nba playoffs are
about to start what are we doing you can
still get your futures in on the mvp
vote as well
you can bet on everything in my bookie
man so look what you got to do is go to
mybookie.com right now
just go to mybookie use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account this is important when you sign
up for a new account use that promo code
bootleg and they will give you
a deposit match free money up to a
thousand dollars so if you sign up and
you put 200 bucks in they're gonna give
you another 200 to bet with
thousand they're gonna give you another
thousand to bet with let's go for the
suns all the way just throw all your
money on the phoenix suns
all right and then bet that the warriors
won't make it out of the first [ __ ]
round because jokic is going to [ __ ]
pound them in their ass probably great
odds on that one anyway mybookie.ag
mybookie just [ __ ] google the [ __ ] my
bookie use the promo code bootleg and
they will match your deposit free money
free money up to a thousand dollars is
it still like uh if like someone from
northern california gets locked up in
southern california she gets hectic for
them no
that's only on the mexican side or not
oh yeah yeah because the nurse
well well the nathaniel's in the south
side they ate they got a peach tree
right now oh they do yeah they got a pea
street right now
yeah they could be on the yard together
now so they don't go up with them but i
know the bulldogs and the south siders
they is what are the bulldogs bulldogs
are they they um they're from the north
too
oh yeah friends no fresno i mean
yeah
but uh
so so yeah fresno
yeah fresno i've been to fresno one time
i was like i don't know if i ever need
to come back here again it was cool i
was just when i right before i just got
out
uh at peel call hold on i peeled car uh
they hopped the gate on some on some
south siders that was in line with me
the bulldog was three southsiders in
line with me the police know to keep
them away and one of the police left the
gate like open them next that's [ __ ]
cammy did that thing just like just the
door and start barking after oh
that's what they do they bark
[Music]
tripping i'm like these [ __ ] acting
fresno's wild huh not a lot of people
from fresno but the ones that are ain't
to play with huh yeah
yeah yeah i went to fresno there was
some lovely a lot of extras
a lot of extras i've been to fresno once
it was very small you know i had some
dutch brothers they had a dutch brothers
there good coffee yeah went to a taco
festival it was a good time are you
gonna be hitting the road at all you
gotta wait until probation's over no
yeah i can hit the road you can go
anywhere go anywhere well not out the
country right right but you can travel
within the states for sure like without
a doubt how are you gonna um
not fall victim to what other la artists
have fallen victim to and when i say
that i mean
there's a lot of la artists who have a
hard time breaking out of the la so
the california yeah
ceiling i was just talking about this
bro we know so many people that are so
talented and are amazing artists but for
whatever reason it ain't lit for them
past like texas or new mexico
i don't exactly i know i know what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna start [ __ ] with
[ __ ] outside [ __ ] with my atlanta
people my memphis people some people
have done that
like uh i think roddy probably is like
the prime example of the last like five
years of somebody who just transcended
everything right yeah
that's that's that's that's the way i
think kailyn's done a good job of that
because i think what caitlyn did
that i think more artists from la should
do
he kind of like went down to atlanta and
just stayed out there for a while it's
happening with the
exactly
so i mean yeah i mean with your network
i feel like i'm going to do that you
don't want to and i feel like with the
your sound it's it's
you got you could do the melodic [ __ ]
the rapid [ __ ] you could do so much so i
just i know that like
i love there's so many artists in la
that i love but i just i'm like damn
like either the music they're making or
just
you know the way they're moving they're
very the the ceiling is low exactly and
it's like man if you could just figure
out a way to get out of the right right
break that baby yeah you could go do
your portland your phoenix your [ __ ]
baker's field but it's like that's all
the same what happens if you go to rally
north carolina right or miami or [ __ ]
buffalo or something [ __ ] you know what
i mean
so so for you it's just tapping in with
everybody exactly i need to target that
audience bro but i'm on it i'm owning it
i'm telling you i'm is that something
that you're like aware of like
immediately i'm on my analytics that's
that that's all i do is check that [ __ ]
out like i want i want to see how the
public really [ __ ] with me and where
where i need to grow at you know what
i'm saying so i'm i'll be on that [ __ ]
all day if you're on your spotify you'll
see oh [ __ ] this city's [ __ ] with me
yeah like i might need to go tap it out
there like like
all the [ __ ] for artists all the
analytics to tell tell you
like what you need to do like where you
need to target this and that and you
know i'm saying this who [ __ ] with
you just where it's low as it tells you
so like
that's what it is read that [ __ ] there
it is man well listen uh the new project
is coming out when i know you're just
trying to make april 29th yeah i just
dropped elevate last night so next
friday this was that next friday next
friday next friday
man elevate uh videos out elevate video
out uh shout out to empire man shout out
to devo you know i'm saying they really
uh who's your project manager at empire
devo oh dave well shout out today
dave was project managing over there
yeah salute today
today man for real there it is man yeah
so album on the way in uh
hopefully you have a really active year
man stay free i will i'm gonna stay free
stay free bro for sure that's my best
advice to you
you can't be on it if you ain't in it
you know what i'm saying for sure i
appreciate you though yeah
appreciate you pulling up
like a podcast